My name is Robin Kelsey, and
I'm Dean of Arts and Humanities
and a professor in the History
of Art and Architecture
Department.
And it is my great
pleasure to welcome you
all here this evening.
Because we have two authors with
us, two books, much to discuss,
I'm going to keep my opening
remarks and my introductions
of the speakers
very, very brief.
I would just say
that in recent years
it has become clear that
one of the issues upon which
the humanities need to
train their attention
is on the very
issue of attention.
As teachers, we are witnessing
a generational shift
in the conditions of
attention, a shift
riddled with societal anxiety
about failures of attention,
about deficits and disorders.
And at Harvard, we
have concentrations.
But really, who can concentrate?
This evening, we will take some
time to talk about distraction.
I think it's the perfect
end-of-semester topic.
Those of you who have been good
enough to join us this evening
can hardly be asked to give your
full attention to this event.
You should give whatever
fraction seems right to you.
Hewing to the spirit
of this topic,
our conversation
may wend and wander.
It can dive a gate
down cul-de-sacs,
or drift off into reverie.
Very excited-- at least
part of me is anyway.
So we have two wonderful
scholars with us this evening
to help us to come to terms
with our inconstant attentions.
I'm going to
introduce them both,
and then each will
come up in turn
to talk about their
most recent book, which
is in one manner or another
addressing the topic at hand.
So I'm going to start with
Marina Van Zuylen, who
joins us from Bard College.
Marina is Professor of French
and Comparative Literature
at Bard, and also serves as
the national academic director
of the Clemente Course
in the Humanities,
a program with which some
of you may be familiar.
It's an amazing program
that brings the humanities
to low-income adults.
Barack Obama has already
thanked her personally
for this service.
But I think we should add our
own gratitude on this occasion.
She is the author of a lovely
new small volume entitled
The Plenitude of Distraction.
And indeed there is a
plenitude of thinking in it,
despite its very handy size.
She is also the author of
two wonderful other books--
Difficulty as an
Aesthetic Principle--
Realism and Unreadability
in Stifter, Melville,
and Flaubert; and a book
I particularly love--
Monomania-- the Flight
from Everyday Life
in Literature and Art.
With us also is John Plotz, who
is the professor of Victorian
literature at
Brandeis University,
author of a new book
entitled Semi-Detached--
the Aesthetics of Virtual
Experience Since Dickens.
He is also the author of
two other wonderful books--
The Crowd-- British Literature
and Public Politics,
and Portable Property--
Victorian Culture on the Move.
And I understand he has also
written a young adult novel.
Maybe we'll hear about that.
Neither Marina nor John
is a stranger to Harvard.
But I'd like to welcome
them back very warmly
on this occasion.
OK.
Can you hear me?
Yeah, really?
Because I can't hear myself.
Oh, yeah, OK.
Very good.
Thank you so much for coming.
It's unbelievable
that you're all here.
I wouldn't get out of
bed with this cold,
but I'm glad you did.
First of all, I
want to thank Robin.
I want to thank Steve.
I want to thank John also
for writing this book, which
is, you know, when I was
asked, I thought, whoa,
I wrote this tiny thing,
which I call my pamphlet.
And he writes this.
And I'm thinking, my
god, he's so lucky.
He gets on later.
But actually I love
every page of this book.
So I really recommend it.
And it reads a little bit like
a Victorian novel sometimes.
All right.
So let me begin.
I'm going to just introduce
succinctly, I hope,
what my book is about.
So I decided to write this
book after I taught a class
on promoting good idleness.
And many of the
students in this class
confessed to me that
they were on Adderall,
and they were on Ritalin, and
they let me on to the fact
that their pills made them feel
overly focused, helping them
maybe get better results on
their papers, on their exams,
but robbing them
of the pleasures
and intellectual enrichment
of delayed gratification.
They told me that they
missed the open time
that they thought
should be associated
with novels and poetry.
The class turned out to be an
unexpected exercise in soul
searching about the connection
between success, media,
technology, and the
lost art of slowness.
It also reminded me,
while I was enrolling
the students of this
class, it reminded me
of my first really hugely
traumatic experience,
which happened many, many,
many years ago at Harvard
as a freshman when, after taking
some little test the first day,
I was told that my reading
skills were particularly poor--
how great for the
self-esteem right away--
and that I would have to
enroll in Harvard's very
special speed-reading class.
The first morning,
about a hundred of us,
looking very sheepish-- and
none of us told our families--
so we sat in this
huge amphitheater.
It was the Science Center.
And large chunks of text were
projected on a giant screen.
The instructions were clear.
We needed to distill
what we read,
and answer pointed
questions in order
to indicate that we had
grasped the argument.
There was an obnoxious person
next to me, this woman speed
reader who spoke so fast that I
couldn't imagine for one second
that she needed to
take this class.
And she looked at me,
and she said, oh, I
understand that you're a
Russian literature major.
Well, this class is going
to benefit you immensely,
because you will be able to
read The Brothers Karamazov
in a fraction of the time.
I was, needless
to say, horrified.
Who is this person?
And she came from Belgium.
And, I mean, I came from
France, so there was already
this tension between us.
[LAUGHTER]
So this horrible
experience was decades
before the various
slow movements
were encouraging
people to linger
over their foods
and their futures.
We had no computers
back then, remember?
And we would never have dreamt
of something I hope never
have heard of, which is
Google's Popular Passages,
a program that lets you
explore a book in 10 seconds,
pointing out what really
is important when we read.
Naturally, no literature
lover could either
have designed either
Google program,
or that atrocious speed-reading
class, which actually
never helped me in the least.
So Darwin, as you
will see, would
have been the first
objector to this kind
of traumatic
speed-reading experience.
In this stunning entry from
his journal from May 1st, 1881,
he bitterly concludes
that extreme focus
can be dangerous-- in fact,
more dangerous than distraction.
His extreme focus on
evolution, he writes,
ended up shriveling his brain,
shutting out his favorite poets
and musicians, and impairing
for good his judgment of taste.
I'm going to read
you a passage which
is really heartbreaking
and beautiful from Darwin's
journal.
"Up to the age of 30 or beyond
it, poetry of many kinds
gave me great pleasure,
and even as a schoolboy
I took intense delight
in Shakespeare.
I have also said that formerly
pictures gave me considerable--
and music very great-- delight.
I have tried lately
to read Shakespeare,
and found it so intolerably
dull that it nauseated me.
"I have also almost lost my
taste for pictures or music.
My mind--" then pay
attention to this,
because it's quite
heartbreaking--
"My mind seems to have
become a kind of machine
for grinding general laws out
of large collections of fact.
But why this should have
caused the atrophy of that part
of the brain alone on which
the higher tastes depend,
I cannot conceive.
"If I had to live
my life again, I
would have made a rule
to read some poetry
and listen to some music
at least once a week."
Once a week.
That is really
pitiful, Mr. Darwin.
Once an hour.
Well, he hated
leaving his house.
He did.
That's true.
"The loss of these tastes," he
adds, "is a loss of happiness,
and may possibly be
injurious to the intellect,
and more probably to
the moral character."
So if losing one's train of
thought is such a bad thing,
then why didn't
evolution fix it,
providing us with a
steel-like concentration?
Could it be that destruction
grants us actually
a secret survivalist weapon?
Unlike our primate siblings,
with their fierce capacity
for fending off enemies,
finding food, securing shelter,
we are programmed, for
better or for worse,
for making light
of our condition.
As the great anthropologist
Albert Piette--
P-I-E-T-T-E; he should be
world famous, and he's not--
as Albert Piette notes,
as opposed to gorillas
and chimpanzee,
being human means
to inhabit a presence
absence mode,
to practice detached
attentiveness,
letting the minor and
major modes coexist.
This minimalism, he
writes, allows us never
to get too deep
into things, dipping
as we are in
activities peripheral
to the situation at hand.
So what can we learn from
the fact that only humans can
be simultaneously
absent and present,
detached and connected--
thank you-- active and passive.
I think it is, because we
daydream, zone out, lose
our thread of a conversation,
that we can perhaps
stop ourselves from
being fanatics,
forget the harshest
blows, and move on.
Many of you surely
remember a comment
Primo Levi made in If This
is a Man, where he suggests
that the paradoxical view
that divided attention might
have done more good
than harm in Auschwitz.
Despite his unthinkable
misery, Levi
felt grateful that at least
on one fateful day the wind
was not blowing too hard.
So what do we make of the
fact that only Homo sapiens
is capable of the kind
of existential detachment
that tolerates an idea that
goes nowhere, a thought that
is never carried through?
The upside of this
is that we will
endure, far better
than primates,
a weirdly constructive
cognitive blurriness.
So what if we can concentrate
on our work all the time?
I know we're worried about that.
We're worried every time
we look at our telephone.
we Google John Plotz.
Oh, that's how I recognized
you-- because I googled you.
So swaying between
crucial or less crucial
occurrences may well constitute
strength, and not weakness--
a very idiosyncratic type
of intellectual creativity,
one that feeds on
divided attention,
and helps us balance the
playful and the tragic.
You all have read that
neurologists experimenting
on ways people
solve problems note
that our best chance of
getting something right,
getting a solution, is
to indulge in downtime.
As you know, Nietzsche never had
an idea without perambulating.
He needed to walk aimlessly.
He needed to daydream
and to get lost in order
to have that thought
that was somewhere
in the back of its mind.
Indeed, putting
the riddle at rest,
and storing it at the
back of our minds,
rather than focusing
on it ad nauseam
liberates the
circuitry of thinking.
Hume's wonderful formula,
the storehouse of labor,
recalibrates perfectly
the dichotomy
between work and play,
attention and inattention.
Thinking in a straight line,
monitoring our every thought,
is basically a losing battle
more and more, and we know it.
Our innate way of relating
to our surroundings,
and to our own thinking
patterns, is non-directed.
Trapped by competing sensory
and intellectual stimuli
we are, and it is,
essentially absent-minded.
Tristram Shandy's meandering
account of his birth
is a case in point.
The more Sterne's
protagonist attempts
to control the intricacies
of his own autobiography,
the more facts keep creeping in,
crowding his initial narrative,
until it loses its
shape altogether.
But let's go back to
David Hume for a moment--
the wonderful David Hume.
Hume cultivated an associative
random playful relationship
to things as part of
a desire to stray away
from this straight line,
and experience life
as a series of rich,
disconnected moments.
To begin with, Hume's
resistance to single-mindedness
coincides with a
warm-blooded engagement
with worldly matters.
While concentration seems to him
solipsistic and self-involved,
distraction, he muses provides
kinship and community.
Let's think about that
when we're suicidally
looking at our text messages.
This is what he writes, and
it's one of my favorite quotes.
"I dine-- he writes
that when he was just
monomaniacally attempting
to disprove Descartes.
And he just hated Descartes.
But he got so
obsessed by Descartes
that he thought, how
am I going to get away
from this French, crazy man?
I will play backgammon.
I mean, maybe that's what we
should be doing right now.
This is what he writes--
"I dine, I play a
game of backgammon,
I converse, I merry
with my friends.
And when, after the three
or four hours of amusement,
I would return to these
Cartesian speculations.
They appear so cold, so
strained, ridiculous,
that I cannot find in my heart
to enter into them any farther.
I still feel such remains
of my former disposition
that I am ready to
throw all my books
and papers into the fire"--
please don't do that,
you graduate students
with your dissertations--
"and resolve never more to
renounce the pleasure of life
for the sake of reasoning
and philosophy."
So, unlike many of us
beating ourselves up
for neglecting reasoning, and
overindulging in play or text
messages, Hume embraces
banter and backgammon
as therapies against
excessive focus.
So, excessive focus is
worse than distraction.
Take comfort in that.
Excessive focus is the enemy.
Playing devil's advocate to
Descartes's harsh critique
of impure reasoning,
ridiculing the propensity
to chase after
microcosmic dilemmas,
if philosophy promotes such
claustrophobic thinking,
then Hume would trade it
willfully and willingly
for an open conversation.
It may be mildly amusing to
you to know that this small
pamphlet that I wrote--
I like calling it a pamphlet,
because really, I mean,
does this qualify as a book?
I don't think so.
It's like bullion.
It's like what?
Bullion.
Oh, OK.
All right.
So this used to be 300
pages, and so boring.
And I thought, really?
Am I going to torture
my friends who
are going to feel that they
have to read 300 pages of this?
And you did not make me bored.
So maybe I should have
kept it at 300 pages.
But I don't think so.
But I decided to cut it down,
and to make it into something
that people may be
able to read while they
were sipping margarita.
So one of the texts
that inspired me not
to bore my audience
is a wonderful quote
from Kierkegaard's Either/Or.
This is Kierkegaard,
who is following
the vagaries of his
own mind, who is trying
to concentrate on a speaker.
Just like you,
he's sitting there,
and he thinks he's just going
to die, or to fall asleep.
And suddenly he is
jolted out of his slumber
by the least philosophical
part of the experience.
He suddenly notices the
perspiration dripping down
this philosopher's
forehead and nose.
I read to you.
"There was a man
whose chatter I was
obliged to listen to because
of the circumstances."
God knows which circumstances.
"On every occasion he was ready
with a little philosophical
lecture that was
extremely boring.
"On the verge of
despair, I suddenly
discovered that the man
perspired exceptionally much
when he spoke.
This perspiration now
absorbed my attention.
I watched how the pearls
of perspiration collected
on his forehead, then united in
a rivulet, slid down his nose,
and ended in a quivering
globula that remained suspended
at the end of his nose.
From that moment on,
everything changed.
I could even have the
delight of encourage
him to commence his
philosophical instructions
again, just in order to watch
the perspiration on his brow
and on his nose."
As he explains in the prologue
to this comical interlude,
Kierkegaard can be
fantastically funny.
The secret of
pleasurable attention
is arbitrariness, often
the de-familiarized, even
inappropriate kind.
Carried by playfulness
and irreverence,
Kierkegaard ended up
tolerating the trying
boredom of the situation.
What the wonderful
Albert Piette saw
as our great hidden
strength, the ability
to be simultaneously
present and absent, Mister--
how could I call him;
brain-numbing and joy-killing--
Heidegger sees as our doom.
Believe me, I love
Heidegger too, sometimes,
but boredom is something that to
him, as opposed to Kierkegaard,
is absolutely necessary.
So let's not focus on
someone's perspiration
when we read Heidegger.
In fact, Heidegger wants us
chained to our attention,
chained to our boredom,
advocating scrupulous
attentiveness.
He berates his readers
for drifting off,
for going after
short-term satisfaction.
Focus must be redirected to
the delicate textures of moods.
"Without boredom,"
warns Heidegger,
"we will go through
life like automata,
not experiencing
anything in depth.
Time would be mindlessly
allowed to fly by, and be
frittered away.
Only boredom, if fully
realized and grappled with,
will keep us
existentially alert."
We can debate this afterwards.
I would like to finish, because
we only have a few minutes.
I want to finish
with a marvelous
quote that my wonderful
niece, who just finished
her dissertation, and who
is doing a lot of googling,
I think, in her free time.
She wrote to me and
said, for your lecture
you need to read this.
And I have to confess, she
said, I got it off Wikipedia.
So I am finishing this lecture
with a quote from Wikipedia.
That's a pretty good
confession, right?
How often do we tell our
students that this is directly
from Wikipedia?
So "Adam Smith,
writes Wikipedia,
"was described by several of his
contemporaries and biographers
as comically absent-minded,
with peculiar habits of speech
and gait, and a smile of
inexpressible benignity.
He was known to talk to
himself, a habit, that
began during his
childhood, and he
would smile in rapt conversation
with invisible companions.
"According to one story,
Smith took one of his friends
on a tour of a tanning
factory, and while discussing
free trade, he walked into a
huge tanning pit, from which he
needed help to escape.
He is also said to have
put bread and butter
into a teapot, drunk
the concoction,
and declared this is the worst
cup of tea I have ever had.
According to another
account, Smith distractedly
went out walking
in his nightgown,
and ended up 15
miles outside of town
before nearby church bells
brought him back to reality."
So I just want to thank
you for being here.
And if you don't
buy this book, do
try to get it on
Google's Popular Passage.
Remember, it's a program that
will let you understand it
in 10 seconds.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Sorry.
So I'm going to hide behind
a PowerPoint a little bit.
So, thank you so much,
Robin, for this event.
And thanks to Sarah and to
Steve for organizing it.
And Marina, thank you so much.
It's great.
I threatened that I was going
to read the Kierkegaard passage
from Marina's book
if she didn't.
So it's like a Good Place
episode, or something.
It's fantastic.
So it is a really great
pleasure to be here tonight,
and to take part in
what I look forward
to being just an open
conversation, and freewheeling.
But like Marina, I'm going
to just talk a little bit
to set things up.
So the way I would frame
it is that nowadays we
have diagnoses
like ADD, or ADHD,
and we have the account
of social media addiction,
or Google-itis, to anchor our
discussion of distraction.
And so maybe we could think
about that amazing eyeball
as the figure for that.
Though I have to
admit to me it has
kind of a Nordic Sauron vibe.
It seems more hypervigilant
than distracted.
But, you know, I
get it's the problem
of the skipping
eyeball, I guess.
So we have that now in spades.
But I mean, even when
I was growing up,
there were ways of
thinking about distraction
as a common problem.
So I remember as a kid the Monty
Python sketch "Word Association
Football."
I don't know how many
people remember this.
But it's John Cleese telling
you-- it's very hard to do.
I mean, I've never said
it out loud before,
but I got the words.
It's "Word association
football is a technique out
a living much used in the
practice makes perfect
of psychoanalysister
and brother,
and one that has occupied
piper the majority rule
of my attention squad by the
right number one, two, three,
four, the last five years."
So you get the idea.
There, each word, or
even each syllable,
is kicking the distracted
brain or the distracted tongue
away down a fresh pathway
to some kind of fresh hell.
So it's kind of like
language itself as clickbait,
that we're always capable of
being kicked sideways, even
in "technique out a living."
So in other words, there's
a very robust tradition
of understanding
distraction as kind
of free-range
mental peregrination
with, as Marina was
saying, with all its vices.
So yes, new, Robin,
I totally agree.
It is new.
We have a new version of it.
But then we also want
to think about how
much the new version of it is
akin to older versions of it.
So those are recent diagnoses
that medicalize or burlesque
the state.
But in the early
days of the church,
the desert fathers were
obsessed with acedia,
which sort of turns into
sloth or [? decedia ?]
in later ages as a deadly
sin, but originally is
the state of restlessness
and inability
either to work or to pray.
So that's the
original noonday demon
is the demon that distracts you.
And later on here, in the
shadow of William James Hall,
it seems appropriate to recall
a line from his 1890 Principles
of Psychology, which
actually I have
to admit that I got not from
Wikipedia, but from Joshua
Cohen's new book,
called Attention.
But maybe he got
it from Wikipedia.
It's totally possible.
"Attention is the
taking possession
of the mind in
clear and vivid form
of one out of what seems several
simultaneously possible objects
or trains of thought.
It implies withdrawal from
some things in order to deal
effectively with others, and
is a condition which has a real
opposite in the confused,
dazed, scatterbrained state,
which in French is called--" and
I will just say it in English
"--distraction."
However, so there is
this account of attention
good, distraction bad.
And clearly both of us here
are standing in front of you
to discuss ways--
other ways, maybe-- to
think about distraction,
and I think not
necessarily to praise it.
I really don't want my teenagers
to see on Twitter that I'm
in favor of distraction.
But at least not to bury it.
So I thought the best
way to kick this off
is to take about 15
or maybe 20 minutes
to present the argument
of my book Semi-Detached.
And Marina, in terms of the
amazing lapidary concision
of your book, I feel
like about my book
that there's I think
it's a Samuel Johnson
line, I wrote a long letter,
because I did not have time
to write a short one.
So I think you went ahead
and wrote the short one.
But I kind of
wrote the long one.
And it is about this
idea of semi-detachment.
So I'm just going to talk
a little bit about that.
When you half lose
yourself in a work of art,
what happens to the half
that is left behind?
The critical vocabulary
to describe that sensation
is lacking, but it's a
familiar feeling nonetheless.
When most carried
away, audiences
of even the most
compelling artwork
remain somewhat aware of
their actual situation.
Ideas about this kind of
semi-detachment play a crucial,
and I think an
under-explored role,
in shaping a wide range
of modern artwork.
So the argument of
the book is, yes, this
is a kind of phenomenological
account of this feeling.
But what I want to
show is that there's
a lot of artworks
where the artist must
be thinking about this.
I mean, this is an
intentionalist account.
So Marina, you very
rightly pointed
to a key attribute of how we
think about distraction, which
is that the reader
should be free to pick up
what they want to pick.
That's the kind of
Roland Barthes account,
and pleasures of the
text, that the text
may be there because
the author put it there.
But either reader can take
up or put down what I want.
And I agree with that as an
important way of thinking
about what the conscious state
in front of a work of art
is, as it is in
front of the world.
But my argument is that the
artworks I want to talk about
are ones where in the
inception of the artwork
you already see that the
person making the art
must have understood that kind
of doubleness as part of it.
That isn't just a
readerly response
that could be arbitrary,
it could be anything,
but it's also a response to
something that's really--
you can show it to be
present in the contours
of the artwork itself.
So I'm saying that
this is modern.
And for me, it's really the
last couple of hundred years
that I'm interested in.
But it is definitely
there earlier.
So in this 1595 amazing
painting by Caravaggio,
for instance, which I
was sort of lucky enough
to see in Canada early
days of this project, what
I'm going to say--
and I think I'm not
going to talk a ton
about this painting,
but I'll come back to it.
It's called The
Musicians, but I'm
interested in the
central musician.
So his hand on the
strings, the music
that we can imagine
going through the air,
his gaze out at us, which is
the gaze of kind of attention
and inattention at once,
because, of course, he's tuning
and he's listening, but
he's also looking out at us.
But he's also not looking out
at us, because he's just canvas.
He's just color on canvas,
so he's not really looking.
But we kind of want
to catch his eye.
But even if we
caught his eye, we
wouldn't really catch him
looking at us, because he's
listening to his instrument.
So this play, this kind
of back and forth where
we want to be drawn in, there's
a kind of claim of absorption.
But then there's also
the reminder-- but wait,
it's more complicated than that.
You're outside looking
in at the same time.
So in such words,
in works like this,
the crux of an
aesthetic experience
is imagined, or
depicted, or understood
as residing neither in complete
absorption in an artwork,
nor in critical
detachment from it,
but in the odd fact of both
states existing simultaneously.
So I'm not an art historian.
I was going to say I'm
a fake art historian,
but I'm not even a
fake art historian.
Not an art historian.
But so let me just talk
about just a couple
of literary passages that
I want to talk about today.
And so this is probably the
most important one for me.
In George Eliot's The
Mill on the Floss,
in the first chapter
moves from an account
of the young heroine--
Maggie Tulliver, you
may remember-- at play
to a description of the benumbed
arms of the narrator who
has been watching her.
"It is time the
little playfellow--"
so the narrator is
speaking to us--
"It is time the little
playfellow went in,
I think; and there's a very
bright fire to tempt her;
the red light shines out
from under the deepening
gray of the sky.
It is time, too,
for me to leave off
resting my arms on the
cold stone of this bridge."
Ellipsis-- Eliot's
ellipsis, not mine.
"Ah, my arms are
really benumbed.
And I have been pressing
my elbows on the arms
of my chair--" like this kind
of chair "--and dreaming that I
was standing on the bridge in
front of Dorlcote Mill as it
looked one February
afternoon many years ago."
So Elliot has an image of
a doubled elbow rest here,
the bridge and the
chair arm both.
And I think that
offers a way to think
about the reading
of the novel itself.
Not only am I here reading,
I'm also there absorbed
into their world.
The narrator turns
into a simulacrum
of the reader, whose dreamlike
entry into Maggie's world
is bodied forth in that
ellipsis-marked discovery
that the arms had been pressing
onto the bridge and the arm
chair simultaneously.
So one April morning,
not very far from here,
biking over the Mass Pike,
listening to my iPod,
back when there were iPods,
with traffic noise in one ear,
and the Carter
family in the other,
I suddenly came to think
about that moment in James
as a fact of life,
not just of art.
Holding two things
in my head at once--
cabin in the pines, and
also the broken glass
that I'd have to dodge at
the end of the footbridge,
suddenly struck me less as
a quirk of George Eliot's
armchair doubling, or,
yeah, elbow doubling,
and more as a record
of something that
had been happening to me
all my life, only happening
in this evanescent and
unsatisfactory way,
happening and then vanishing
again because I lacked
the vocabulary to
make sense of it,
to give it a name
and some attributes,
and in that kind of scholarly
way, to try to historicize it.
So the title of Sherry
Turkle's Jeremiah,
wonderful Jeremiah,
but Jeremiah,
about teenagers' over-networked
lives Alone Together,
began to strike me
less as an indictment
of our present social
condition than as a description
of our perennial
residence in a state
of mental quasi-abstraction.
So I biked straight off that
bridge, and into the library--
in fact, Widener Library.
And sometimes it seems
that I have not left since.
So just because it
took me until the 2010s
to have this realization
did not mean, of course,
that other people hadn't
been having it before me.
And one of the joys
for me of Marina's book
is to think about the
two of us discovering
different genealogies
of this way
that this is a thing that is
new now, and yet also keeps
on happening in earlier times.
So just to read you a Ford
Maddox Ford quote, "It is,
I mean, perfectly possible
for a sensitized person,
be he poet or prose writer,
to have the sense, when
he's in one room,
that he is in another,
or when he is speaking
to one person,
he may be so haunted
by the memory or desire
for another person that he may
be absent-minded or distraught.
Indeed, I suppose
that impressionism
exists to render those
queer effects of real life
that are, like so many views,
seen through bright glass."
So this is the double
image that he's setting up.
"--seen through glass so
bright that whilst you perceive
through it a landscape or
backyard, you are aware that,
on its surface, it reflects a
face of a person behind you."
So do you guys get that?
It's like lens.
It's pass-through and
lens, or mirror slash lens,
and also pass-through
at the same time.
"For the whole of life
is really like that.
We are almost always in
one place with our minds
somewhere quite another."
And here, not just under
the shadow of William James,
but also footsteps away
from 20 Quincy Street,
where William and Henry lived--
it was before the Harvard
Faculty Club was built on the
ruins of Henry's bedroom--
we might also give some
thought to Henry James.
Here he is describing the
protagonist of the tragic muse.
And he picks up distraction,
and twisted a different way
from William.
So you remember William
talked about the-- let me get
the exact words--
William talked about
the "confused, dazed
scatterbrained state."
But what Henry says is, at this
moment when he has sort of met
this fetching new person he's
become interested in, "There
was a new infusion in
his consciousness--
an element in his life,
which altered the relations
of things--" a new "distraction"
in the French sense "--he could
recognize that as freely as
possible without being obliged
to classify the agreeable
resources as a new
entanglement."
So I take it there
that an entitlement
would be kind of like
what William James was
talking about with attention.
An entitlement would kind of
anchor you to that person.
But this is the
agreeable possibility
of it being is a free relation.
This infusion is kind
of a free infusion.
And by the way, since
both the James brothers
talk about this
as being French, I
was like, OK, well, I'm
going to look at the OED.
And in fact, if you
go to 1526, hard it
is to say one paternoster
without distraction of mind.
So in fact it's a
perfectly English--
I mean, it is a
long-term English phrase,
that the fact that people
think of it as French--
I don't know, Marina.
Maybe you have something
to say about that.
They don't call it
Belgian, that's for sure.
Yeah.
But yeah.
And that 16th
century usage of it,
you can see there that's a
sort of an acedia problem,
like when I pray, I find
my mind slipping away.
So that's really a
classic distraction.
OK.
So we both came to this question
of how do we think about this.
And I think for both of us,
what I wanted to emphasize--
and I'm not going to talk
a lot about the next slide.
But there is a way to say we
live in this world of beeping,
and buzzing, and
tweeting, and chirping.
I don't know if anyone's
seen the new Wreck-It Ralph
movie, about Ralph
entering the internet.
I don't know.
I had not been able to imagine
how many different forms
of social mediation
you could discover kind
of swarming in on you at once.
And Ralph sort of
experiences them all at once.
And so you could
see the alternative,
like Patrick Leigh Fermor's
wonderful book about going
to a monastery, or this
interesting book by Kathleen
Norris called
Acedia and Me, where
she talks about taking
on the burdens of time
by going to the desert.
There's this Georgia
O'Keeffe painting
I love to look at that has
that kind of desert serenity.
But that's not the story,
I think, that either of us
wants to tell about
what the alternative is
to thinking about distraction
as just pure noise and babble.
Instead, we really are
thinking about things
like this Caravaggio
painting, this notion
of the music that is there,
and is somehow kind of torquing
that relationship we have to
the central musician figure.
Maybe it's somewhat
different with a guy
looking out over his
shoulder with a sort
of more what I think of as a
Caravaggioesque come-hither
look.
But the difference
between those two faces
may be giving us some sense of
different ways of looking out
of a painting at
you calling you in.
And then I talk a little
bit-- though, again,
I feel very out of my
comfort zone here--
about this amazing poem which
I just covered at the MFA,
but painting-- interesting--
Hans Memling, Christ
Blessing, in which
really what I care
about here, which is not
easy to see on the reproduction,
but the way that the hand just
rests on this
seeming frame, which
is a little bit of
a trompe l'oeil,
but it isn't really
a trompe l'oeil
that has meant to
have a gotcha effect.
It's meant to more
just establish
that the Christ is with
and not with you, that he's
out there in that space, but
also somewhat potentially
present in your own space.
And I do feel a little
bit more comfortable
talking not about paintings,
but about Buster Keaton movies.
So I'm going to show actually
a couple of short Buster Keaton
clips, if there's time.
But, wait-- there's no time?
Am I out of time already?
Ah!
Thank you.
OK.
Well, I'm going to be fast.
You can show it.
Really?
Can I show them
my Buster Keaton?
OK.
And then I have a
little bit more to say.
But OK.
So with Buster Keaton, the
point I wanted to bring up here,
with Keaton sort
of in the 1920s,
I just love how Buster Keaton
is able to think about what
it means to kind of be
wrapped in your own world,
and then suddenly
discover that there
is a real world that intrudes.
So we could talk a lot about the
comedy of Buster Keaton which
unfolds in a lot
of different ways
in terms of his investment,
and kind of mechanical comedy.
But the emphasis for me, like in
the context of semi-detachment,
the character, Buster, is
always moving through the world
alone, and then just coming to
realize things about that world
that he had not grasped.
It's almost like he's got kind
of a transcendentalist problem,
like I saw the tree was there,
but I just didn't realize it.
So what I see in Buster
Keaton over and over
is that way that the world
kind of changes around him,
and then he has to come back
into consciousness of it.
So in this case,
he is terribly shy.
He really wants to
ask Mary to marry him.
But he's never
been able to do it.
So he decides to go off and
practice his proposal alone,
as he feels he is alone.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[END PLAYBACK]
OK.
And by the way if you're
asking, did I actually
see a black-face character?
Yes, you saw black-face
character at the beginning.
That's a whole different
discussion about Keaton.
But I want to acknowledge
there is a black-faced gardener
at the beginning of that
clip, which I didn't really
talk about here.
But, yeah.
So that moment of kind of
coming out of yourself, where
the rehearsal becomes
real, for me, those
are really fruitful spaces
to think about the way
that this kind of
semi-distraction
or attentiveness,
but attentiveness
that lets your mind
be somewhere else,
that that's what Keaton is
talking about and thinking
about.
And I don't know the
anthropologist you mentioned,
Marina, but I really
should, because that
question of detached
attentiveness,
I think that's a lot of this,
that Keaton is out of the world
and then back into it.
So just quickly, I'm going to
maybe take five more minutes,
let's say.
All of these instances
here are cases
of the kind of being out
and then coming back in.
And there's another
Henry James quote, which
I'm not going to talk about.
But I just will say quickly
about The Ambassadors.
I think The Ambassadors is full
of this, that Henry James uses
free indirect discourse, great
creation of the 19th century
novel.
He uses free indirect
discourse to show people
thinking that they
are in the world,
and then discovering
that something is going
on right next to them
that they had not heard,
which in this case is expressed
"That indeed might be,
but meanwhile,
she was going on,"
which is a moment where we
realize that the character has
been talking to us as if
he knew what was going on,
but he's missed something
that the other character has
said to him.
So I think James
is really a master
at thinking about that
way that when you think
you're in and of this world, you
are actually also checked out
of it.
And then I'm going to just show
one other Buster Keaton clip.
This is from a short
film called The Boat.
And the point here is what
he is doing is decorating
his cabin of the boat.
And he is completely right to
want to decorate the cabin,
because that's what one does
in a space that belongs to one.
You just put up a painting,
and then you feel at home.
But he's also completely
wrong, because he's in a boat,
and the cabin is underwater.
So the problem is double.
It's a cabin, and
it's also the ocean.
And then it's
complicated by the fact
that the painting itself
is a painting of the ocean.
So that's the kind of wrinkle
that kind of tells you
the awareness of Keaton there.
So here we go.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
There he is, nailing
the painting.
And then it starts leaking.
[END PLAYBACK]
And then, yes, and
then he later creates
another hole in order to let
that water out, which is great,
which he then covers
with a pancake.
And it goes from there.
But I hope you guys caught the
most interesting moment here.
It's not so much, oh,
the wall is leaking,
or, oh, there's water
coming out from behind it.
It's that moment where
he touches the waves.
Because that's the
moment where he's like,
well, there is an
inexplicable water,
and there's painting of water.
So where am I here?
And that moment of
shifting registers,
like that location is, it's
really fascinating to me.
I think that's the moment
where Keaton is thinking.
And in that Sherlock
Junior, if you guys
know that film, which is about
literally a projectionist who
jumps into his own film, that's
a film that ends explicitly
exploring this, because
the projectionist has
to look at the picture of
two people kissing in order
to understand that he
himself in his life,
he ought to be kissing
the girl next to him.
So it's a moment which makes
very explicit that this
is about the shifting
of frames, and not
knowing whether we belong
in one frame or another,
but also discovering,
as Marina was saying,
we belong in both at once.
So I'm going to not talk
about William Morris.
This would be the
connection to talk
about my William Morris
children's book, which does not
look like this.
But I will just, yeah, I mean
I guess I'll basically stop.
The only thing I'll
say is I sort of
have a final question,
which is, after I
picked this incredibly--
I love this photo,
this 1895 photo,
which is a photo of the
photographer's daughter.
So a portrait of her--
a portrait of Aude in the field.
And then, of course,
I realized, maybe
a year later, I realized, oh,
but it's echoing this Caspar
David Friedrich.
So on the one hand, this is
this incredibly beautiful
enigmatic picture of my
daughter in the field.
It's sort of her imagining her
consciousness belonging to it.
And on the other
hand, it's this echo.
It is kind of canonizing,
or putting her
into that larger world.
So one thought I had
about distraction
is that we just live in
a world where there's
lots of horizontal
transfers, where you're here,
but there's a
resonant association.
There's something else
you're thinking of.
And do we always want to
call that distraction?
I mean, that would seem like
a kind of depletion of the way
in which sometimes
reference in this way,
or sideways dislocation, or
mental wandering and return,
that seems like that is actually
part of what we call attention.
If you're really good at
intertextually collating,
we call that a
form of attention.
But it's also a skitter.
It's a jump away
from your present.
So that quality of how the
jump away may be actually
like the higher
form of attention.
OK.
So that's it.
[APPLAUSE]
Should I turn it off?
You can leave it on.
Well, thank you.
Those were wonderful
introductions of the books
that you've produced.
And I think it was
clear that there's
a tremendous amount of
possible exchange between them.
I want to start out on something
I took from each of your talks,
which was the extent to
which you were underscoring
certain forms of continuity
with the past, with respect
to the issue of
distraction and attention,
which is really in
contradistinction
to many anxieties that are
currently being articulated
around distraction.
And I thought I would play
devil's advocate a little bit
to test this.
And actually I'll start,
Marina, with your book,
because there's a
lot of ambivalence
in your book around
continuity and discontinuity,
and whether or not the
forms of distraction
that we find in our many
forms of electronic mediation
really are the same
as or different
from the forms of
distraction which
many of the authors
you cite are praising
in fascinating
and engaging ways.
So I wonder if also part of this
is a question of nomenclature.
I mean, when you make the
move from, say, distraction
to reverie, do you suddenly
have to discount certain things
that you would include
within distraction,
but would not
qualify as reverie.
So I just wonder
if the two of you
could say a bit more about
these historical relations,
and the extent to
which we may be living
through certain
forms of rupture,
and whether there's
some question about what
language is required to map
these historical relations.
John, you can answer
about my book.
[LAUGHING]
I'm testing you.
It was so short.
I just want to make
sure you read it.
[LAUGHING]
I mean, well, now I
feel like a freshman.
Can I take a speed-reading
class instead?
You can.
Well, no, I mean, of
course there's something
very disingenuous about
my book, because I
suffer immensely from the
fear of being distracted.
And I've always been a
very distracted person.
And I was going to tell
an anecdote, which is
so personal, and so unacademic.
Should I?
Yes, yes.
All right this is basically
shirking the question.
But about 10 years
ago, when I still
had use of the Harvard
University Health Services,
I had a bad headache.
So I went, and I got an MRI.
And the doctor sat me
down, and he said, well,
I have very, very bad news.
There's a whole part of
your brain that is missing.
[LAUGHTER]
I tottered out of the
doctor, and I thought, well,
I'm going to think of
this in a different way.
All right, I have part of
my brain that's missing.
It's the speed-reading part.
I don't know.
And I said, well, maybe that's
why I always have been felt
very close to certain topics.
So I've written about boredom.
I've written about idleness.
I've written about laziness.
And I thought maybe my
impairment has enabled me.
I see people looking
aghast in the audience.
The X-ray was wrong.
[LAUGHTER]
Basically there was a
whole part of the X-ray
that didn't record.
So about a month later, the
guy called me back, and said,
don't worry.
Everything's OK.
But in the meantime, I
thought about this a lot.
And I thought, well, we
all have certain problems.
I've always been a
very distracted person.
I mean, I was a terrible
student in early years.
And so I gravitated
towards those things
that were more of the reverie--
for example your question,
what happens when someone asked
me a question with
the word nomenclature,
my brain closes instantly.
So it was like the
X-ray was right,
because the word
"nomenclature" completely
makes my brain turn off.
But so what I'm trying
to talk about in the book
is how there are
certain ways we have
to understand a weakness
that is actually a strength.
And I think what
John does in his book
that I felt very, very
close to is understanding
what does fiction do for us.
And we know that Don
Quixote is not real.
And you were quoting
Gallagher as saying,
we don't love Don
Quixote because he's--
how does it go?
It's because it's a fiction
that we're drawn to it.
We're drawn to the unreal.
We're helped in
our world by a kind
of consciousness of unreality.
And to me, the way that I can't
quite think in a straight line,
I can't think about
a nomenclature ever,
actually has helped me be very
receptive to other things,
and especially to fiction, and
especially to all the quotes
that you have from
the Victorian novel.
So that was a non-response.
But at least you know
about my brain, now.
I think that's personal.
But it's kind of a great story.
It's a great story.
So can I pick up
the history angle?
Yeah, sure.
Thank God.
So that phrase that you were
talking about from Gallagher,
I think it's believable stories
that do not command belief.
And so that's interesting
way of thinking
about something
that could be true,
but does not claim to be true.
And I totally agree
with what you're
saying, that that is the
interesting gray space.
But the fact that
you have fiction
doing that in the
18th century, the fact
that Florence Nightingale
spends a lot of time complaining
about what a sketchy
age we live in.
We live in the
age of the sketch,
where nothing is
serious anymore.
Everything jumps around.
That does kind of make
me feel that there's
a pattern of novelty that we can
trace back a really long way.
And what the actual
novelty is is different.
But kind of the attack wave
of those cultural shifts,
or technological shifts, I
think there is some similarity
in the attack wave.
But I totally take
the point, also,
that the affordances of one
age, like the affordance
of the printing press, or
the performance of the radio,
or film, which obviously
was, in its day,
seemed terribly
distracting to people.
But the affordance is still
different from the affordance
of the internet.
Yeah, there's a wonderful piece
by Krakauer called "Boredom."
And horrified, the idea
that all these neon signs
and the radio, all
these are taking us away
from the kind of Pascalian space
of existential consciousness.
And when I disparaged
Heidegger, it's
only because I spent so
many months of my life
reading Heidegger, and
going into this kind
of masochistic
concentration tunnel,
and then getting out
of that and thinking,
why am I doing this to myself?
It's not really me.
It's a kind of
nomenclature of something.
So I think, of course,
it's not a new thing.
But we are in a moment of
extreme anxiety about our lack
of concentration.
But to take it even
closer to home,
it'd be interesting to poll the
room and see if people agree.
But I was thinking about
the way the telephone worked
as a technology.
When we were kids it
drove our parents crazy,
because we're all supposed
to be here as a family,
and you have the telephone,
and it allows you, essentially,
to surf the web.
By calling your
friend, you are surfing
the web of your friends.
And now the telephone is
just this horrible old people
technology that people hate.
Nobody wants to talk
on the phone anymore
below a certain age.
The parents are saying, why
don't you phone your friends
anymore?
Yeah, exactly, because phoning
would be a form of presence.
And it would be real
and qualitative.
But OK, but 35 years
ago, that's not
what people thought
the phone was.
So I definitely think
we're in a new age.
I just wonder if it's
newly new, or if it's
just kind of oldly new.
Yeah, I can certainly see that.
But I think that my
experience as a teacher
is that there have definitely
been changes in the way
that attention is mobilized
by students, or not mobilized.
And I had an interesting
experience a few years ago
when I was teaching
a tutorial, and we
read Bachelard's The
Poetics of Space.
And there's passages--
beautiful passages.
You cite the book in
your book, Marina, where
he's talking about boredom.
And my three students
could not understand what
Bachelard was talking about.
I mean, literally seemed like
they could not understand
what this experience was.
And for me, it was a
moment of, oh, your world
is quite different from
the one I grew up in,
in which it is very
easy for me to remember
boredom of a kind that resembles
what Bachelard describes,
right?
So partly I'm less interested
in the anxiety about loss
of attention than I am
interested in the forms
that distraction takes,
the extent to which they're
commodified at a much
accelerated rate now.
I mean, I guess I'm thinking
of Jonathan Crary's 24/7
kind of thing.
And just, it's not a kind of
this has never happened before.
But nonetheless,
just as Buster Keaton
is working with audiences
to get them to understand
how to handle the
problems of attention
in the moment when film emerges,
that we are kind of looking
for models of how to handle
the forms of attention
and distraction
that are available
or not available to us now.
I totally agree with that point.
I remember the first
time I saw people
who do these poetic
experiments using, I think,
is it called Shockwave?
Like Flash players
that you can't control.
Where you go onto the internet,
and the poem just kind of
comes at you.
And I think of
that as an attempt
to cognitively
reckon with what does
it mean to be
immersed in this way,
and discover that turning on
and off might seem to be easy,
but it's actually not that easy.
So, yeah.
I think that's right.
Yeah.
Are we worried that we have
too much focus, really?
Because we're always
looking for something.
We're expecting something.
We need the
adrenaline, the high.
Even getting some stupid
text from someone we hate,
it's still some kind of high.
You have a wonderful
expression in your book,
"Pavlovian creatures
of the internet."
Yeah, we are.
I mean, it kills me that
my students are so unhappy,
because on one level
they're on their Adderall,
and their Ritalin.
And it does help them.
It makes them
write maybe faster.
But they're feeling
they're mourning something
that they don't really
know what they're mourning,
because it's not boredom.
It's something else.
I'm not sure what.
Can I put in a plug
for-- do you know
this new book, My Year of
Rest and Relaxation, Moshfegh.
So I'm only halfway
through now, so it
might turn out to be wrong.
But it's about somebody
who cannot find that place
of solitude and downtime.
And so she medicates
herself to achieve
it, which obviously
has all sorts
of counterproductive results.
But it's this notion that,
what's the Conrad line?
"In the destructive
element, immerse."
You can't go out.
I mean, it would be
impossible for her
to imagine just, oh, I'll go
sit on a farm for a while.
But maybe I can pharmacopeize
my way back to that state.
It's fascinating.
And that is a book that seems
to me to be encountering
the new qualitative situation.
[INAUDIBLE]
My Year of Rest and Relaxation.
Yeah.
I loved how in your book
there's some wonderful quotes.
So John, for instance, contrasts
Lord Jim and Our Mutual Friend,
these two passages.
And in Lord Jim, Lord
Jim is Conrad's character
is reading about these
sentimental novels
where characters save
heroically somebody else.
And he's so immersed in
this that when he actually
needs to come up on
deck and save someone,
nobody's home, because he's
just completely focused,
concentrated on that moment.
Whereas in Our Mutual Friend,
Lizzie Hexam manages--
she sees a man drowning.
And I was thinking of Camus's
The Fall, the famous beginning
of the book.
But she sees someone
drowning, and she
manages to have two things
happening at the same time,
two emotions-- fear
but this courage.
It's "I don't know
this person, but I'm
going to save this person."
And as she's praying,
she's praying,
she's hoping that
this is not happening,
she goes and dives in the water
and actually saves the person.
And for me this was
a wonderful example
of how we can do
many things at once.
And thank god we can have this
presence/absence gift, really.
Because, as Hume would
say, if we're just
thinking about Descartes,
or if we're just
doing what Heidegger would
like us to do, and plunge
into this kind of
important boredom,
we're not going to be able
to cull the kind of magic
of the detailed
magic of the things
that don't seem to matter.
I always think of Mrs.
Ramsay in To the Lighthouse.
You look at her life,
and it's a series of kind
of not very important events.
But those events make
her that full person,
that person who's
capable of loving,
of noticing, of nurturing.
And Mr. Ramsay, who
wants to go from A to Z,
and to understand
all philosophy,
is incapable of
being with anybody.
So it's because of Mrs.
Ramsay's inattention
that she's actually so
receptive to her fellow humans.
And speaking of being
receptive to fellow humans,
I think it's a good opportunity
to open the conversation up
to everybody here.
So there's a couple of my mics.
No nomenclature, please.
No.
No nomenclature.
And you can share your MRI, but
only if the story ends well.
There are mics.
So I see two hands
up in the center.
Samantha, why don't you
go first, and then Martin?
Thank you both for
just really rich topic.
So as a philosopher,
I'm going to ask
a philosophical question.
So let's suppose distraction
is a kind of good.
There's a question of
what kind of good is it.
So there is these certain
instances of I'm Hume,
and I'm trying to
bring down Descartes,
and so going down to
the pub with my friends
is a nice kind of distraction.
So then I can come back, and I
can really show why he's wrong.
So that's an instrumental view
of the goodness of distraction.
But then it's
interesting to then think
about the case of art, right?
And so what has Darwin
lost, or the examples, John,
that you were talking about.
When we are in this
distracted mode.
It's less clear that that just
has this instrumental value
there.
It seems distraction is more
of an intrinsically good state
to be in.
So I just want to invite
you to say a little bit more
about if you have thoughts about
what kind of a good distraction
is.
Is it an instrumental good?
Is it an intrinsic good?
Can I take that first?
Yeah.
I'm really glad
you mentioned that,
because when you were,
Marina, when you were talking
about Darwin, I was
thinking that there's
another 19th century
example, which
I'm sure you were
thinking of, too,
which is John Stuart Mill has
this mental breakdown, in which
he recuperates from
by way of Coleridge.
And he really does kind of
try to unpack that problem,
whether what he
needed was simply
to be able to turn off
the utilitarian brain.
That would be the account that
Bentham is good, but just not
all the time.
You need some commercials,
too, or something.
But he ends up coming
down more on the notion
that there is this other thing.
Which I'm not sure if he
uses the word "experience"?
I have to go back to
Martin Jay's book.
But I mean I feel
like the point there
is that he's trying to get at
something where what he likes
about Coleridge's
poetry as distinct
from other romantic
poetry is that it
fuses thought and feeling.
So by Mills's account
there is this other thing,
which is that it
makes you grapple
with the difficulty of the fact
that though I'm in my mind,
having this one
thought and experience,
somebody else out there is
experiencing differently.
And I can, yes,
somewhat apprehend it,
because poetry somewhat
brings me into their world.
But imagination doesn't
take me all the way.
So I think, if I'm understanding
your question right,
I think what I'm saying is not
just that imagination becomes
like a cure-all
panacea, like when
we have an artistic experience.
It has this great utility of it
gives us a secret passageway.
It's actually more
complicated than that.
It's that the
aesthetic experience,
like trying to catch the eye
of that Caravaggio character,
is at once a payoff.
There's some sensual beauty.
There's some apprehension.
There's something you get.
And there's also a sense
of distance as well.
So I think to me that's--
do you know what I'm saying?
The utility in a way is that
it's a qualitatively different
kind of utility.
Marina, do you want
to weigh in on this?
Because you talk about
that paradox in your book.
Yeah.
I mean, the presence
absence thing, I
mean I was mentioning
briefly Nietzsche,
and how he would say, I
can only really produce
these thoughts when
I'm losing myself,
when I'm not going
in a straight line.
And so again, I always
feel a little bit
disingenuous with this whole
topic, because of course I
want to have the richest, most
intense philosophical life
possible, despite or
because of the distraction.
And actually, I
mean, I don't know
how to put it, that
the presence/absence,
that this anthropologist
who tells us
said we couldn't live
if we lived simply
in the mode of presence.
And so we have to absent
ourselves from depth in order
to get to a greater depth.
And it's hard to
explain, but I really
understand that,
how sometimes, I
mean, when you're
talking with someone,
and you hear someone
else's conversation,
and you kind of are dying
to listen to that other day
dichotic listening it's called.
And we're all guilty of that.
But it happens also when we're
watching, say, Breaking Bad.
I don't know how many people--
everyone has watched Breaking.
I never feel guilty when
I'm watching Breaking Bad,
because I'm actually completely
ensconced in a fictional world.
I feel guilty when I feel that
I am basically I'm not together.
I'm pressing this one button.
I'm half-looking at one thing.
So for the philosopher,
I think the philosopher
wants a certain amount of
lost time in order to find
the time that will be
the time that will allow
them to write or to create.
So I think it has a
connection to creativity.
I don't know.
Martin.
So I may be totally wrong, but
I'd like to know what this is.
I think Robin, in your
question, this was distraction.
I'm asking you a question,
but at the same time,
I'm looking something up.
And no one can pay
attention anymore
because they're so distracted.
Marina, I felt like for you,
this was not distraction,
but total absorption.
I'm looking at it, and
I forget where I am.
And I'm looking at it only.
So I would like to
know which it is.
And since there is
this discrepancy here,
maybe, I think John is right,
and it's semi-detachment.
[LAUGHTER]
But I am glad you asked
that, because something
in John's book, I think it's the
only thing I disagreed with--
Oh, good.
--is you talk about this
person who is in a cafe,
and I forget who
it is, in a cafe,
and basically is
feeling terribly guilty,
because instead of partaking
into the conversation,
he's actually doing stuff that
we know when our students are
pretending to scratch their--
I see what you're doing.
You're not listening.
You're actually
looking at your iPhone,
which is hiding in your shoe.
And so in your book,
and I have it somewhere,
he defends himself, or you,
John, defend him by saying,
well, actually he has access to
the in-between at that moment.
But I actually don't
think it's true.
I think the in-between
comes when we float,
we daydream, we get lost.
But the phone for me
is total absorption.
And I have to say what I'm
looking in my shoe as well--
I've done it, too--
I'm lost to the
rest of the world.
And that's what I hate.
I hate that I'm no
longer receptive.
I'm actually
absolutely directed.
So for me, that little
thing is the direction
that I don't want.
I don't want to be like that.
I want to be able to
half-understand maybe
a conversation, but
not completely be
able to turn into a
monk of the iPhone.
That's our desert, there.
Marina, have you ever seen that
movie Pillow Talk, the Rock
Hudson--
Of course, with
the feet, and the--
Yeah.
Because that seems
like it's about that,
the phone having that quality.
So in my role as
splitting, as being
the synthesis, or Aufhebung.
I think the word
I would go back to
is the word affordance there,
meaning that cognitively
there's just all sorts
of tools and technologies
that hit the human species.
And they each allow
different capacities.
And Marina, I think
you're right in saying
that for you the affordance
is allowing you the window in.
But Robin, I think you're
also right in saying
that you watch people get
glimmers and distraction.
And that's my experience of
how my teens use their iPhones.
It's terrifying to me.
They put down books
and picked up iPhones.
And that's what they do.
So Martin, I mean, that's
an unsatisfying answer.
But it's a tool like any other.
And it's a tool
that can kick you
in a bunch of different ways.
And I think what I was
trying to argue at the end,
but it's not a
fully-formed thought,
is that I was making
the case that sometimes
what one man's distraction
is another man's attention
kind of thing.
It actually depends on
the angle we pick up
before we can say
definitively that that is.
Yeah.
And maybe the
philosophers can actually
finish my thought here.
But one of Deleuze's
most wonderful pieces
is when he talks
about monads, and when
he talks about Leibniz.
And Deleuze actually uses
that to talk about Proust,
and says that--
I actually have
the passage here,
but I've lost my glasses
because I'm distracted.
So I probably can't read it.
But it's an end here.
So just maybe you
read "For Leibniz"?
"For Leibniz the upper
floor is the soul,
or what we might call following
Guattari, the corporeal aspect
of subjectivity.
As Deleuze remarks
in an interview,
'Leibniz's most famous
proposition is that every soul
or subject--
monad-- is completely closed,
windowless, and doorless,
and contains the whole world in
its darkest depths, while also
illuminating some little
portion of that world,
each monad a different portion.
So the world is enfolded in
each soul, but differently,
because each illuminates
only one little aspect
of the overall folding.'"
So I love that passage so
much, because we are monads.
And so in some
ways our propensity
is to turn the world inside.
It comforts us in
some strange way
to have that little telephone.
It's a form of not
wanting to leave your bed.
And I love not leaving my bed.
So I understand that desire.
And so if we are monads, there
are certain moments where,
thanks to Caravaggio, thanks
to a Proust, a window opens,
and a window opens
to a part of us
that suddenly we didn't
even know was there.
And I think so many
of your examples
is about this double life.
We live a double
life all the time.
Our double life is
the life of our past.
We have so many moments of
our past that we suppress,
we put in a corner.
And then suddenly it happens.
It's there.
And that part of our life is
just as much a part of us.
But actually we don't
always access it.
So we are distracted
because we're only always
a tiny fraction of who we are.
And in fact, we're this
hugely complex machine
that just gets revealed by
chance, by conversations.
So I feel that our little phone
there tries to get us to buy,
get us to focus, gets us to--
it's a commodity.
It's those things that
are not commodities
that makes the little monad that
we are into something plural.
Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE]
Could you take the mic,
just this because this--
yeah.
Thanks.
Yeah.
I also wonder whether
it has anything
to do with lapsing
from cognition,
or from the vocabulary
of cognition,
into, I don't know whether
to call it affect, or drives,
or do you see what I'm saying?
The opening of the windows.
Getting out of the monad.
Yeah, just.
I guess.
I don't know.
What do you think?
Well, can I circle
and come back to that?
I mean.
Because to follow up on
what you were saying,
Marina, about that notion
of the multiplicity
of available things
sort of in the self,
and how we figure out which are
the things that are actually
part of the order of
our lives, I really
love the point you made
about Tristram Shandy, about
the piling up of stuff, the way
that there's all these episodes
that just kind of go.
And I think one of
the things I try
to argue in the
book about the novel
is that what defines it, the
novel, is that it is episodic,
meaning there's a bunch
of things that happen.
And then the order, like
the narrative sequence
that pulls it together,
that looks like one thing
at the beginning.
But then later, after a bunch
of other episodes have occurred,
it may turn out that
other of those things
were more important.
So in other words, things
that look like distractions,
detours, like
off-ramps on your life,
when you look back at them.
I feel like Middlemarch
is constructed of nothing
but off-ramps.
And then in retrospect
it turns out, oh,
that thing that happened
to Mr. Bulstrode
20 years before the novel
began, that's actually
a crucial aspect of his life.
So in other words, I
think, the artist part
of narrative artistry is
to say the things that
look like they might just
have been kind of out there,
and had nothing to do
with anything else,
in retrospect there
is an order to them.
So again, that goes
back to the point
where things that look
like distraction or detour
actually turn out to be
part of the mainstream.
I'm sorry.
That's not a good
answer to your question.
I apologize.
I thought it was
going to connect back.
The nomenclature of your
question was complex.
[LAUGHTER]
Other questions?
Thank you.
So I have two quick questions.
One of them is just
about have any of you
thought about how
contemporary novels try
to respond to these kind
of distractions, especially
the internet?
And the second question is
I guess more in your field.
It's about that
sort of weird thing
where people get accused
in the 19th century
of basically
falling into novels,
being totally
consumed by novels.
And that's really dangerous.
So I just sort of
wonder about that,
especially because it kind of
becomes gendered and stuff.
John will answer
your second question,
because he talks about
that a huge amount.
The first question, there are
many contemporary novels now
that use links.
So you can read them
on the internet.
I mean, you can read
them on your machine,
or you can read them.
And it's two utterly
different experiences.
There's a Paul La Farge novel
which I forget the title of it.
But it's all about
following links.
And I listened to it on Audible.
So I missed it completely.
He teaches with me.
And I said I really
liked your book.
And he said, so, what did you
think of all the references
to our distraction?
And it's, of course, I
didn't get any of that.
And John talks
about the whole idea
of free and direct
discourse, which in some ways
could be a pathology right now.
We are free indirect
discourse, right?
Yeah, but the second question,
I think the immersion
and the danger of fiction.
Right.
But I also take it,
Danielle, you're
talking about quixotism, right?
I mean that is the way in
which, sort of Madam Bovary,
like that quality of--
or the female quixote,
is an interesting
18th century example
of that, where people to
whom the world of books
becomes like real life.
I mean, I just think, OK, I
will mention Wreck-It Ralph
for the second time tonight.
I mean, I think that
so many modern art
forms are dealing
with that notion
that we're living
in game spaces.
I mean, so Wreck-It Ralph
literally lives inside a game.
But I think one of
the reasons it works
is the same reason that
Ready Player One works
for us, which is that
we are constantly
thinking about the fact
that we have avatars.
We have a kind of
fully developed
internet mediated personality.
Maybe our being isn't there, but
our personality is out there.
We're doing work out there.
People fall in love
on the internet.
And so fine.
So Second Life itself is kind
of dead as an experiment.
But the notion that those
kind of virtual worlding,
that, I mean, I think that
there's so many art works now
that are responding to
that way in which ourself
is kind of partially out there.
What you said reminded me of
a really wonderful experience.
So I taught this Don
Quixote tutorial,
and Bard students
are impossible.
They do theater until midnight.
So sometimes our tutorial
was from 11:00 PM to 1:00 AM,
because those were
the only times
we could all find together.
And we were talking
about Madame Bovary,
and the dangers of fiction.
And one of the
students said to me,
we are Don Quixotes,
because we inhabit
the world of virtual reality.
My brothers and I had
a terrible childhood.
Our parents were abusive.
The only place where we actually
had a life was in these games.
What are they?
I mean, games, and--
Well, they're
called [INAUDIBLE]..
Something like that.
I don't even know
the terminology.
But it made me
stop in my tracks,
because I'm so old-fashioned.
It's just reading
is the only thing.
And I actually, no.
They had this beautiful,
these memories.
Their memories were
memories of passing,
doing some dangerous
things that were virtual,
that were not real.
Their reality was miserable.
Their virtual
reality was something
that they could share,
something they will remember.
Remember, when he told me.
He talks to his brother
about this as his childhood.
So this is such an
incredible thing.
I was blown away by that.
And it made me feel
I am so prejudiced.
These kids have-- you
guys, the youngsters--
have such rich lives
compared to stodgy me.
We just had the telephone.
Although--
And you could ask, you could
do the thought experiment,
if movies had come
after games, what
would the cultural
reaction to the movies be,
where it's just like
you're being broadcast at,
like you're being
brought into that world
and given that world,
whereas in the game space
you're playing with it,
and interacting with it?
And so maybe that would be
the culturally valorized form,
rather than--
But of course when
Don Quixote sees
a puppet show, and he
thinks they're real,
and he destroys them.
And then Orson Welles
makes the Don Quixote movie
which is so great.
And Orson Welles makes it
as Don Quixote and Sancho
at the movies.
And when Don Quixote sees
these characters galloping
on the screen, he gets up and
destroys the screen-- totally
destroys the screen.
And so I don't know.
Do we live as intensely, and
is it so terrible to live?
But can I just
answer that question
in a slightly
different way, too,
Danielle, which
is that I do think
there's a ton of novels
nowadays that actually
do bifurcate the
internet persona
and the lived experience.
In other words, there
is a kind of old person
account of, oh, 19-year-olds
are on Facebook all the time.
Therefore all their
whole being is bound up
in their social transactions,
and their badges,
and all these other things.
And for example, Sally Rooney,
I really love both Conversations
with Friends and Normal People.
And both of those are about
the difference between what
you appear like in
that persona that's
out there electronically,
versus the kind of depth
that you yourself possess, which
is inarticulate and struggling,
because it's
personal, and it's not
personality, which is what
gets played out out there.
In other words, I
think there's probably,
just like in every
generation, there's
a range of artistic responses.
And one of them is to say, well,
there is that electronic space
there, but then the real me
is kind of hidden down here,
and likes to be alone.
Just take a couple
more questions.
Yeah.
Thank you so much.
I would like to explore the
possibility of meditation,
and granted the reality
and multiple manifestations
of distraction.
Now especially preserved with
technology and media, media
as medium and communication,
but what is also the practice
and calling of meditation.
It is in this context your
reflection on presence/absence.
Now the presence/absence
can be uncultivated,
or it can be cultivated.
So what is the pathways
of cultivation of presence
and absence, and in the
terms of more a reckoning,
and therefore, whether
it also requires
a fundamental critique of some
of the assumptions, like monad.
Now the idea of the
monad is related
to monotheism in some ways.
So therefore, how do we embrace
a cross-cultural perspective?
And looking at the individual,
though [? with windows, ?]
but not necessarily as monad,
a different configuration
of the one and the many,
and therefore Heidegger--
Heidegger's notion of not only
monad, but being in the world--
despite all problems
with Heidegger,
how do we cultivate
that modality
of being with the world?
Well, of course,
through boredom.
I mean, the three
stages of boredom
in his concept of metaphysics,
there's a real training.
I mean, if one takes Heidegger
seriously about boredom--
and I did another crazy tutorial
just about boredom for a year.
We were never
bored, but it really
is he takes us through the
steps of being able to,
first of all, understand why
we can't tolerate, for example,
missing the train, having no
phone, no clock, no timetable.
We don't know when the
next train is happening.
How do we actually get
out of that predicament,
and meditate rather than
have an anxiety attack?
And so you have to read those
150 pages to get the answer.
And I recommend it deeply,
even though the consequences
can be medically severe.
But I think boredom is, profound
boredom, conscious boredom
would be our answer
to meditation.
It's one way of
looking at meditation.
I don't meditate, but I
try to accept my boredom.
And I have a tiny, short
answer, but I really
want Theo Davis to give
it, rather than me,
even though I know she won't,
because it's about Thoreau,
which is just to say
that for me Thoreau
is the way of thinking about
that moment of awareness
of presence.
And just I think so
many of his essays,
including the one "Walking,"
that I quoted briefly there,
really try to grapple
with a conscious encounter
with Eastern religions
that he was having.
But that, right, I
mean, just there's
so many different ways to
think about what the presence
of a self that is a non-monadic
self in a natural environment,
I find those essays
incredibly though provoking.
Thank you.
Thank you very much
for both your talks.
I have to confess that I was
so intrigued by the Frenchness
attributed to this
distraction-- distraction--
that while you were
speaking I went down
an etymological rabbit hole
on my distraction presence
object to look up
distraction, the [FRENCH]..
And I learned that it has to
do with separation, or tearing
away.
And I thought, oh, well,
you know, distraction, how
does that work with extraction?
Because extraction
seems like the function
or the result of attention, or
the opposite of distraction.
If you are really attentive, and
you are extracting something--
[? Like an oar, yeah. ?]
--an object, which is also
about separation and detachment
and removal.
So that was very kind
of perturbing to me,
because I thought, well, if
you're present and inattentive,
and that puts you in
a dynamic of removal,
or if you're distracted,
and that still puts you
in the state of removal,
is attachment possible?
There's no there, there.
Yeah.
Or are we just doomed to a
state of either being removed
from the world,
or always removing
a part of the world from itself?
That's a beautiful question.
I am kind of speechless,
because of course there's
no answer to that.
But there's a despair.
There's always been
a despair about it.
I mean, I think I write
about this in my book.
I read yours, but I
didn't re-read mine.
But Jonathan Edwards
doing a real training
program in order to
not be distracted,
and how he couldn't
manage to do it.
I mean, it's like St.
Augustine trying not to eat,
and the less he
eats the more he's
obsessed about food,
that there's really,
if you want this perfect
attentivity, attention,
you're thinking about
something you desire.
And you're not actually in
that space of meditation.
You're actually in
a disembodied moment
when you're focusing
on the attempt.
And the etymology
that you're presenting
is incredibly compelling.
And the only thought
I have to add
to that is that from what
I understand about acedia
in the early days of
the church, that's
really a form of the problem.
Because the point
is that the acedia
comes to monks who
are committed to kind
of meditating, and
being with the divine,
or considering the divine.
They're not doing
intellectual work.
They're doing work.
I mean, they're doing thinking
in the orientian sense.
They're just trying to
think the thinking that
ravels and unravels.
And the danger is
that when you do that,
you might attain something close
to a divine, but demons come.
I mean, the problem of
acedia is demons coming.
And the demons are
really beautiful.
So the problem is
that you actually
have succeeded in conjuring
up something which
you want to be a divine,
but might be demoniac,
because you've gone astray.
And they couldn't get out that.
And I think, as I understand
it, Augustine's solution
is basically
[? consentobitism. ?]
In other words, you can't
be monadic as a monk.
You have to be cenobitic.
So he has these injunctions
about going and eating meals
together.
Like that's how you
solve the noonday demon,
basically, is that
you have lunch.
Yeah, you can't be alone.
But you give something
up by doing that,
because you give up the
possibility of extracting.
Because the revelation
you have might actually
be a grounded revelation,
but it's too dangerous,
because it could be demoniac.
And it's ecstatic.
Ecstasy is dangerous, as
we all know all the time.
Lunch is safe.
So the mention of lunch,
and Augustine and hunger,
is making me hungry.
So before the
beautiful demons come,
I want to thank our two
wonderful authors, Marina
and John, for a
fabulous conversation.
[APPLAUSE]